my house does kind of smell it's
starting to smell a little bit like cat
piss
not a good thing nice dude because
apparently
it's like permanent cat pee yeah it's
like you can't get it out
that's why i like covered litter boxes
are i guess so popular because like once
the
the um
aura or what's the word i'm looking for
the distance the odor of cat piss
like explores your house there's no
getting it out that's why reddit stinks
every time i open it
yeah
like every time i open it on my phone
like
ugh the hell is that
it's the cat pee yeah
making its way through the internet
that's insane
and another thing about cats is you
heard about this like
this like parasite
have you heard about this before no okay
so the movie
uh yeah have you heard about that before
yeah great movie yeah great film uh i
only watched the first 40 minutes but
loved it yeah
um okay so cats carry some parasite okay
the parasite needs to reproduce in a
cat's stomach okay and what so once it
infects a mouse
it affects its judgment center in its
brain so it's more daring so it's more
likely to get killed by a cat
so the parasite can breed in its in the
cat's stomach
right
so but this also affects
humans and so
apparently there's like a super skewed
number of the p of the amount of people
that die in motorcycle accidents that
have cats
like it's super skewed to people who
have cats because a lot of them have
this parasite
that makes them more daring
isn't that [ __ ] crazy
and it also makes you like cats
so it kind of like put a spell on you a
little bit is this like one big ruse so
you can buy a motorcycle
no babe you don't get it i have no
choice i have the parasite the parasite
is taking me over i have to get a ducati
no i have to go to vegas yeah and gamble
yeah
i have to babe on my it's the parasitic
parasite it's making me do it
she's got a dumb just a dumb partner
okay
where's your where's your husband this
weekend the parasite made him go to
vegas again bro i gotta get a cat yeah
yeah man it was a sick investment
[Laughter]
this is it right here
toxoplasma
it also yeah can mess with all sorts of
mice behaviors
um
it turns mice's fear of cats into
curiosity
that's another thing it does that's what
i'm saying that's what i meant by it
puts a spell on you
wow
also you're right on the money
with motorcycle accidents yep
so how do you know if you have it do you
just walk past the harley-davidson
center and you're like
yeah
i don't know what's wrong with me i've
never
honey
you're just in there swiping your card
already
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i can't control it
getting onto
it i don't even know how to drive this
but i don't want to do it something is
making me do this i don't want to do it
i don't want to do it
i hate it i hate it right off a cliff
right into the brick wall in the
showroom
damn
30 to 60 of humans worldwide i'd have
this [ __ ] yeah can you transfer it if it
gets into a human can you pass it to
another one
i think you'd have to eat the human
[ __ ]
god damn
this is a
take to get rid of it you said what
there's a pill you can take to get rid
of your motorcycle addiction
oh you can cure it i thought it was like
once it's in you it's in you like uh
close this cut this out cut this out cut
this out why
because if i buy the motorcycle
what i want to lean in knowing that
there's a cure
oh
wow
so once you have it there's no going
back you just have to like the
motorcycle
oh i just had a really dark
please
tell me
is that why people like killed cats
why
what do you mean you know these crazy
like cat murdering people
i don't think like
again 30 to 60 percent of people have
this yeah but do they wake up one day
and they're like you put the parasite in
me
i don't think so i cannot run my card
for any more motorcycles i've already
bought four you [ __ ] spell binding
demon you
be gone no because they're like wired to
like cats then oh that's right yeah once
it's in yep
it's in yeah that's why people become
cat ladies and cat people that's why
actually why
that is so that's why they have 20
because there's a parasite in them yeah
telling them what to do i i mean i think
like that's part of it obviously it's
not
super
crazy like the power of this it's crazy
i guess i've never heard this so
it's extremely surprising to me yeah
holy [ __ ] my mind is blown yeah yeah and
i found out all this after i got a cat
so i was like [ __ ] great
perfect
so that's why people with cats look like
there's just like
it's like their brain has like holes in
it what do you mean like when you look
into a cat person's eyes you could just
tell like there's something gone yeah
yeah
and it's because they've been
lobotomized by this yeah that parasite
eats part of your brain yeah clearly
it's super crazy that's what it would
take to make you want to buy more cats
one quick search on the internet shows
you cats are dicks we like i know i kind
of i kind of get it
kind of get what now that i have them i
get why people end up with like 10
because they're not a lot of work they
just yeah and once you have two more
than two they like keep each other
occupied really yeah by beating the [ __ ]
out of each other they just like wrestle
and play and like lick each other's ears
and [ __ ]
they do yeah and i'm just picturing you
with like red swirls in your eyes with
20 cats like no the cats are good
[Laughter]
the cats are good for you dude this is
gonna be your whole house cats and
motorcycles
[Laughter]
honestly sounds like a sick house yeah
yeah see this is how it starts this is
how it starts yeah if i ever end up with
a harley you know
you know why because i hate motorcycles
yeah i don't get them at all that's such
a crate so this parasite is like
you know
if you're a toxic person you should be
learning from this parasite master
gaslighter no you said you always like
motorcycles
i never said that yeah you did
i do like motorcycles yeah you told me
you told me it's always been your dream
no i'm too [ __ ] for one i think
for someone like me who's a
[ __ ] yeah you know
i think the
the parasite probably would affect me to
the point where i would like bird on the
sidewalk
that's more dangerous yeah that's
actually
way more dangerous than a motorcycle
yeah they actually did a query on the
people that die on birds yeah
and i'm sorry they did a what a query
[Laughter]
yo
i told you dude
you can't say that
like i'm all okay like the famine thing
is where i stop okay
continue
um
yeah i was just gonna say they did a
like
statistically people that die on birds
are
dumb
really yeah
they're so they're bird-brained yeah
yeah exactly
nice
thank you yeah
what is that true how do they do that
what
when someone's head has been cut like
canned open from riding a bird on the
street does the corner just pick the
brain i don't know that's a good
question
but that was fake what i just said
oh damn it i don't think they've done
any queries on bird i was hoping dumb
snow i don't think so just some this is
some [ __ ] idiot in la with his head
split open and they take his brain to a
lab and they're like and they just
confirm this guys yeah this guy's
yeah we missed nothing
yeah you see this and they're just like
smacking his brain around
this is like raw meat
nothing in there
you